I get the point I understand the point
you can predict how I'm gonna vote okay
therefore I have no free will I mean
that's what you know st. Augustine
disprove that but but nonetheless
the point is that that this which you
don't read in the paper and you don't
know so I'll tell you things you might
not know you might know them that you
might not we hear about 80 cases a year
were unanimous in about fifty we only
take cases know forty probably half of
them 50 percent little under fifty
percent we take cases almost exclusively
on the basis that the lower courts have
come to different conclusions on the
same question of law that's why we can
have a case involving was the comma in
the tax code after a certain word
meaning mean the next word which is for
should be read as a which or that we had
a case like that I liked it no one else
did it but that but but the case about
Guantanamo you say now about 50 percent
the lunder are unanimous the five four
is that you read about are about twenty
percent and they're not the same five in
four so just out of curiosity the year
before Nino Scalia dot I went back and
looked and his vote which is one vote
would have made a difference in four
cases out of about eighty and last year
we came to four four because we were
four or four most of the year because
there weren't there weren't there was an
appointment missing so so there were
three I think maybe for three or four
where it actually split like that so I
had sort of your question to I thought
yeah but why why is it I mean what I see
every day as I see judges trying to do
their best in accordance with what they
think the law demands now of course the
word Liberty doesn't explain itself does
it I mean at least not in cases that
come up to us nor does the word
abridgement of the freedom of speech
black used to say no law means no law
yeah that's true but the freedom of
speech doesn't quite explain itself so
when you get to those big open cases
what is it well it's have been there
20-some odd years as I said and and I do
not think it is public opinion zero
politics no I I talk for most of my
career but for a couple years I worked
for Senator Kennedy which I loved
and on his staff I was counseled
judiciary and I think politics is where
the votes it's gonna be popular not by
bomb not popular no I don't see that so
you say no no you say I'm putting words
in your mouth because I get this form of
question very often I say it's ideology
that's what it is ideology you mean am i
Marxist you know Adam Smith free
enterprise her a Maoist
troublemaker uh well uh ideology you
know if I think I'm deciding a case
because it's good for people generally
you know just generally good and some
ideological sense I know I've done the
wrong thing I can't say it never happens
but people try hard not to do it but I
was born in San Francisco I grew up in
the 1950s I went to Lowell High School a
state school I've had the life I've had
I've had the upbringing I pad and by the
time you're well along in years and
you're in a profession you have views
not views that are too specific but very
general views what's the law about
what's our country about what's this
document about how does law relate to
the people in it very general views a
part of you out of your upbringing out
of your experience and you can no more
get rid of them you can jump out of your
own skin now you say does that affect
decisions when they're open yeah it does
and we hope that you can make
predictions even they're somewhat true
because otherwise I'm being inconsistent
with my basic values and a judge who is
inconsistent is a judge whom the public
has no control over because the only
control over the judge who is appointed
for life is the control of reason is the
control of law interpreted through
reason and if there isn't that reason if
you can't understand the explanation if
you can't understand and seeing how in
symbols that are basically the same
are being consistently applied then
there is no control so what you have in
what explains my puzzlement which was
quite similar to yours is that probably
with different presidents different
political groups will urge the
appointment of a person who has certain
basic views that those people in the
political world think will lead to more
decisions in their favor that they like
but the judge thinks he's doing it
according to the law and the principles
that he holds and moreover presidents
are often and those political groups are
often very surprised Teddy Roosevelt
appointed Oliver Wendell Holmes because
he thought Oliver Wendell Holmes would
be a secure vote for his view of
antitrust within four months Oliver
Wendell Holmes had come out the other
way and Teddy Roosevelt said I could
appoint a judge with more backbone
carved out of a banana he was furious he
was furious and president who thinks the
judge is always going to decide his way
is really under a some kind of cloud of
delusion a judge who think a president
who thinks that the judge will share
certain basic values about America and
the Constitution and the law yeah he'll
be closer there to you might be very
wrong as somehow as somehow and so there
we are that's the best I can explain it
and you see the the it is not political
in any sense that an ordinary person
would ordinarily take as being political
you can't say quite never because of the
role in which sort of basic ways of
looking at things like law and life and
and and and the kind and the country and
the nature of the government and so
forth and all these things some of which
I talked about because those are are in
you and you can't particular oh you
can't get rid of them and you shouldn't
get rid of them and there perhaps
sometimes useful when you come to those
very big basic questions I hope that's
helped
you